his love for subwoofers and electronics
is what created the stage name for our
next guest Jesse Cardone AKA subtronics
grew up playing the drums in the Streets
of Philadelphia an internship at a
recording studio began his career to
become one of the biggest bass music
producers and performers in electronic
music his debut album fractals landed at
number four on the billboard dance
charts and tonight he kicks off his
anti-fractals tour at the downtown Las
Vegas event center let's welcome to the
show subtronics hello dude it is great
to have you here man thank you so much
for having me I'm like Beyond honored
this is incredible thank you well this
is big so it was last year he had a huge
sold out tour yes tonight you're
starting your your new tour tonight how
do you feel about the whole thing
um I'm unbelievably excited it's by far
the biggest thing we've ever done
um just like being able to put together
such an amazing team of people that have
all worked collaboratively so much
um I I feel like the the vision of
everything is is so come together at
this point that I just feel amazing
about it and I'm so excited and so proud
and I just can't wait to present what
we've all been working on and what I've
been working on musically uh and yeah
I'm just incredibly excited I can't wait
your fans are excited let's go back to
to Jesse Cardone in high school I mean
you worked at Target right I actually I
worked at Target in College college okay
but in high school I worked at uh Acme
Markets a grocery store very about East
Coast grocery store now we were doing
Acme and Target were you kind of
manifesting this whole thing or did you
stumble into this career 100 yes uh I
and I like have very Crystal Clear
memories of being in Target
um fan and a friend of mine who was a
kind of a mentor uh got kind of tapped
by Skrillex around that time and troll
face
um and I would literally Daydream
fantasize about troll face and Skrillex
driving up out front at Target and being
like quit your job we're going on tour
right now and like literally to this day
when I see a tour bus I have like I
think back to fantasizing a Target
and like I have like Crystal Clear
memories of like listening to releases
on labels that I wanted like small small
labels pushing carts in the snow being
like if I could just get it one song on
this label I would be content forever
um and yeah it's beyond surreal and I
can't even begin to wrap my head around
even the past few years let's let's go
outside of Music you're a Philly guy yes
are you excited about the Eagles
um yes always the thing I always say is
I'm legally required to feel incredibly
passionate about them I am an Eagles fan
um I grew up in like the Donovan McNabb
era so she had a he had a loss yeah a
heavy one yeah I was like I was fully
emotionally in it like totally invested
and I must have been like 12 or 13 when
we made it to the Super Bowl and I just
had my soul just stopped so ever since
then I mean I'm not too big of a sports
guy but like being from Philly like it's
what's important you know and when we
won the Super Bowl a few years ago like
absolutely yeah you're gonna weep over
that I walk past the the hallway in the
airport where they have like the
memorial and I'll tear up then like
years later I'll tear up because I'll
think of like the Always Sunny episode
where they show the Montage yes of
everyone celebrating and like it was the
most real instance of just like complete
Harmony and like Philly is a city where
like it's aggressive and people you know
fight and stuff and so literally living
being in Point Breeze Southwest Philly
and watching all my neighbors run out
into the street and just like people
that were days before fighting in the
streets now they're hugging each other
like just crying an emotional thing it
was heavy like positive emotional heavy
powerful I gotta get ready to wrap it up
real quick but tonight's show yeah what
can we expect at tonight's show so many
lasers I mean a crazy production great a
crazy production biggest production
we've ever done
um I'm blown away that we've gotten to
this point
um a lot of new music a lot of new
visuals uh a lot of lasers big giant
production it's gonna be Over the Top
Productions put me on a lot of new stuff
we appreciate it subtronics downtown Las
Vegas event center go check them out Las
Vegas now will be